[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben ich zeige euch heute
diese supersüßen fluffigen hefe teilchen
mit einer orion hotel erfüllung die sind
wirklich super lecker und einfach
nachzumachen
für den süßen hefeteig benötigen wir 500
gramm mehl 250 milliliter milch die muss
unbedingt lauwarm sein
80 gramm zucker 80 gramm geschmolzene
butter einen halben hefe würfel das sind
21 gramm wie könnte aber auch
trockenhefe benutzen ein paket und eine
prise salz als erstes gebe ich die hefe
in eine große schüssel gibt dann den
zucker dazu und die blaue warme milch
verrühren das ganze miteinander und das
muss dann zehn minuten lang arbeiten
nachdem zehn minuten gebe ich die
flüssige butter dazu die prise salz und
rühre dass mail unter
[Musik]
und den teig kneten wir dann circa sechs
bis acht minuten bis er schön
geschmeidig ist
[Musik]
danach gebe ich den tag zurück in meine
schüssel gebe da ein küchentuch drüber
und lass es ca 30 minuten lang aufgehen
natürlich könnt ihr den teig auf 45
minuten lang oder eine stunde lang gehen
lassen
hauptsache der verdoppelt oder
verdreifacht sich sogar außerdem
brauchen wir für unsere füllung nutella
350 gramm die habe ich leicht erhitzt
dann ist die streichfähige und 170 gramm
urios aber das innere habe ich
rausgenommen wir brauchen nur die kekse
die oreo kekse mich jetzt ganz fein und
geben sie dann zu meiner nutella
[Musik]
ich habe hier mal wieder eine viel zu
kleine schüssel benutzt deswegen war das
umbringen ein bisschen schwierig also
nimmt am besten eine schöne große
schüssel
[Musik]
jetzt mache ich mit dem teig weiter
dafür kriege ich ihn mir noch einmal
ganz kurz durch und stechen mit 80 gramm
große kugeln ab
[Musik]
die teil kugeln gebe ich mir auf meine
bemehlten arbeitsfläche und gäbe da
etwas frischhaltefolie drüber dann lasse
ich sie noch mal 15 minuten lang gehen
damit man sie besser verarbeiten kann
jetzt nehme ich mir jeweils einen teig
stück gebe dass auch mein schneidebrett
und rolle das oval aus
er nehme ich mir ein esslöffel von der
leckeren nutella orio füllung und gebe
sie auf das erste viertel auch von
meinem teig und rolle dass einmal ein
verschließt den teig gut damit die
füllung nicht rauskommt und nehmt euch
dann ein messer um vier fünf oder sechs
streifen einzuschneiden
danach wollte den tag nach oben auf und
formt ihn zu einem hörnchen
[Musik]
zum verstreichen brauchen wir noch 2
eigelbe mit einem esslöffel milch und
das gebe ich dann auch meine fertigen
heimchen
[Musik]
die kommune 280 grad ober und unterhitze
für 20 minuten in den ofen
auf die hörnchen gebe ich jetzt noch
zart bitter vollmilch und weiße
kuvertüre
[Musik]
zum schluss gebe ich noch ein paar
leckere und dann sind die hörnchen auch
schon fertig
[Musik]
ich zeige euch noch die leckeren
fluffigen hefe teilchen einmal wie sie
im innern aussehen und die sind super
lecker ich finde vor allem nutella und
orion und kombination einfach
unschlagbar ich hoffe dass euch das
video gefallen hat und falls ihr mehr
davon sehen möchte dann dürft ihr mich
sehr gerne abonnieren bis zum nächsten
mal aufs kitchen